the Joe Rogan experience I don't have
anything in the stock market anymore
because we're not for a Barrett
collapsed and I saw I literally saw
people that were working there for 30
years lose everything because they lost
their job and they were reinvested in
the company which they say you're not
supposed to do but this company like
bear-like built itself on being like
like loyalty and like you know like like
work for us help people move ahead and
then they'd reinvest back into the
company you give you get stocks like all
this stuff and then you lost your job
and the stock price went from 130 to $2
you're [ __ ]
did it help you when everything crash to
give you a jump to get him to stand up
and go balls-out no it was art for the
mill yeah because you can see labia out
that's very weird I went out on it was
like I was I was cheap I was cheap
relatively cheap labor it compared to
everyone else I knew I wasn't gonna lose
my job I also came up with a Microsoft
Access program that we used in the
department that no one else knew how to
use really yes so you kind of had your
job locked in yeah but the company could
go under the company could go owner but
it wasn't I was still in the early
enough phase that like I I had no idea
what this whole comedy thing was gonna
turn into and I give you motivation like
knowing that all these people that did
work hard towards a legitimate career
that it could all fall apart on them I
mean that scarred me I think in a
different way
where I was just like oh you can't you
can't trust the stock market like that's
it more put me like it didn't make me
worry about like my career or anything
like that like I I was I think it was
too young to think about longevity
career-wise and I was too new and in
comedy to think it was like that could
all fall apart I was I didn't assume it
was gonna go anywhere anyway
and but it really did like people always
like well you should be invested to be
it like they're like no overtime and I'm
like no I know all the sayings but if it
crashes when you want to retire it
doesn't matter
like if you're 60 or whatever it is and
you want to retire and your 401k just
completely drops well then you gotta
wait what ten more years to retire until
it gets back up to where it was and so
you know keep it in cash baby you know
yeah you're safe at home every now that
you throw the money on the proposal how
bad would that be like you're like I'm
just gonna roll around in this money and
then afterwards you're like I gotta
clean up all this money I test positive
for cocaine yeah you got like you got
every germ yeah if you're naked and
you're rolling around with money it's
the best day that's [ __ ] gross yeah
yeah I don't even like why I like wash
my hands after I touch my should yeah I
mean it's it's everyone's carrying it
yeah so it's it's something that we know
people touch it's like one of the one
things that you know has been passed on
from person to person to person to
person very few objects like a watch or
a light very few objects touched by as
many people as money yeah and often and
strangers yeah dirty people it's on the
ground
it's in a machine nice gross and the
numbers of people that get dollar bills
that test positive for cocaine it's
crazy it's all our charts yeah they did
some study on hundred dollar bills like
the percentage of hundred dollar bills
test positive for cocaine it's really
high yeah yeah it's really high I mean I
guess it would be hundreds yeah hundreds
in circulation you're trying to impress
people you see that Walmart sweater they
got in trouble for yeah the cocaine
they're so lame didn't even know what
the [ __ ] it was yeah they were like no
it's snow no no
he's got a strong his hand that what's
the percentage of dollar bills doesn't
say what it's not legit fecal matter
shut up of course
dirty people wipe their hands with their
own hands just smudge it on their dollar
bills maybe they wipe their ass with
dollar bills when they run on a toilet
paper and then they wash the dollar bill
off in the sink but do a shitty job of
it
pardon the pun I mean if you did run out
of toilet paper solid clean it off in
the sink
says the flu can last for up to 17 days
on the dollar but oh great
mmm credit cards that's why credit card
when people start getting sick just pull
out the credit card that's why when I
was little I ate ate ate dirt ain't
boogers I ate grass good move and I
rarely get sick
good move solid immune system music yeah
that's what people enjoy that was a
gross child for cocaine ninety-four
percent according to 2002 report for
poop ninety-four percent how including
on everything cuz people are gross like
if they always say like there's poop
like there's fecal matter unlike your
toothbrush if I'm like an area of like
how is it getting there but gross we're
disgusting how is it popping with half
and touching railings after you wash
your hands like I was at Disneyland this
little kid was sucking on a chain your
kid [ __ ] chain hooking it up socket on
the chain what's up I was being about
there's so much that's such a high
percentage ninety four per poop and
eighty something for Coke yeah a lot of
[ __ ] people doing coke on
hundred-dollar bill under different
strains of bacteria for animals unjust
unspecified domestic animals
yeah yeah if you wanted to really spread
a disease in this country spread it
through money yeah don't you don't give
you with that idea we didn't tell the
one about the plane I'll tell you that
words tell you my plane idea but yeah
you could it would be really easy if you
had like cocaine on dollars you could
easily just put some sort of a [ __ ]
horrible disease on dollars
[Applause]